but and so basically the influencers
will come in take what they've made and
then make art out of it and then a lot
of times the issue is the influencers
aren't accurate so they'll say things
that are a little bit off or whatever
and that the nerdy guys are like hey
I've been studying this for 20 years
I've done all this work you're using my
work for free can you please just make
sure you get it right give me credit or
whatever they they say because I think
Kevin Samuels they were mad at too and
the guys over here are like Hey we're
the ones actually doing something you
guys are just sitting in your computers
typing when we're the ones creating
movements we're the one making change
like all you guys do is study and just
like that's the way they see it I don't
think the red pill is actually bitching
but that's the way like a lot of the
influencers see it